so you mentioned jody she's often in uh
in your corner and uh does perhaps more
trash talking than even you
so
i mean
if we could step away she's an
incredible human being is sort of as a
fan it's fun to watch the two of you
both when you are arm wrestling and just
as people you just see so much
i don't know kindness and love radiating
from the two of you whenever you're
trash talking or talking about just uh
random things or just talking about life
it's just a beautiful thing to watch and
thank you for sharing that with the
world but
maybe
can you um she paid me to ask you this
what what are the things you love about
jody your wife jody larry
what are the ways she's affected your
life
yeah
jody and i go way back right we were in
high school together
um
the thing that i admire most in people
is is bravery
uh it's to me it's the most admirable
quality
and
jody
always
has inspired me because she's such a
fighter
you know if if she believes that
something's true
um she'll she just she does not back
down she will she will not and you can
and not to say that she's can't change
her mind because
she can but while she is convicted
she will uh she'll not stop fighting
she's pulled me out of the fire
repeatedly
we've we've lived through so many things
um very lucky has she made you a better
arm wrestler
she's fed me
[Laughter]
yeah i could see your uh you have videos
of your house basically coming apart
when she's not there yeah
yeah
yeah without jodi i'm on the street uh
living in a tent and uh yeah down by the
eating dog food yeah
yeah
um
bravery yeah what about love how's love
made you stronger now we're gonna make
uh devin uncomfortable
love is difficult to accept
love is one of those things that um
you know a lot of times
you don't feel worthy of it
you know and so it's hard sometimes to
accept someone's love
and someone who really loves you
they'll love you even when you don't you
know
and
here you go you're gonna make me cry
alex
uh
yeah jody and i've been through so much
um
and she's shown me
how you know
she supported me just repeatedly
repeatedly
some of that is loyalty and patience and
perseverance and all those things that's
like when love really
shows itself yeah sticking through yeah
together for years even when you're
to the the shitty times love and faith
are powerful forces in this universe you
know without them
that we can descend into darkness very
quickly you know as a world even between
people you know when love and faith is
destroyed
then
then we fall apart
you know and i've i've been graced
by by the love that jody's given me you
know it's allowed me to continue to
build
you know when you have love between
people then you build together
um i love
i love
my family i love canada i love the arm
wrestling community i have a love for
what we're trying to achieve as a human
species you know
and uh
you know
when that when that falls apart we don't
have much
yeah
just with my boy there
yeah
you